- [Narrator] This program
is a presentation of UCTV
for educational and
noncommercial use only.
(upbeat music)
- So I think that any time you give a talk
the title of which begins
with The Future of,
you should approach it
with a certain degree
of trepidation.
Predicting the future is a
dangerous thing to try to do.
Now in my normal work, in the stuff
that I work with on a day
to day basis, I am used to
working with instrumentation
that looks like this.
In order to prepare today's talk, however,
I've had to familiarize
myself with a different kind
of instrumentation. (laughs)
And what I'm gonna try to do today is
gaze into my crystal ball a little bit
and give you my sense of what the future
of planetary exploration might hold.
I will begin with stuff that
I feel pretty confident about
because it's gonna happen soon
and the plans are well underway,
and then as I get further
and further into the talk,
I'll wave my arms more and
more and you should all
get more and more skeptical as I do that.
I'm gonna start with
Spirit and Opportunity,
with the Mars exploration
rovers, as Imka mentioned,
the rover Opportunity
is still going strong.
Still doing good things.
We landed way up here
near Endurance crater,
drove 21 months to Victoria crater,
spent two years exploring there
and since then we've been striving
to reach the rim of Endeavor crater.
This shows the route that we followed,
landing site Endurance, Victoria.
Here's where we are today,
there's the rim of Endeavor.
Now this shows the
rover's current location
right there, we have wandered into a field
of small impact craters, four of them.
Their names are Faith 7,
Sigma 7, Friendship 7,
and Freedom 7 after 4 of the
spacecraft that were used
during Project Mercury.
These pictures just came down today.
This is from our current location
looking east at Freedom 7,
looking west at the smaller
crater of the 2, Friendship 7.
You can see these are very fresh craters,
they're rough, they're rugged.
They formed fairly recently,
they haven't eroded away much.
Now it's about the future,
so where are we going next?
Where we're going next is
the rim of Endeavor crater.
And the reason we've
picked it, here's a picture
from orbit that shows what the
rim of endeavor looks like.
The really interesting
thing on this slide, though
is that wiggly black curve there.
That wiggly black curve
is an infrared spectrum
obtained from orbit of the
rocks on the rim of the crater.
And what we've done here is match it up
against three different curves of minerals
that we've looked at in the laboratory.
And you notice that these
dips in the spectrum
line up beautifully.
These minerals are clays.
These are clay minerals,
and clay minerals form
as a consequence of the
action of liquid water.
Now I made the case yesterday
that there has been a lot of water
at the Opportunity landing site.
And the rocks we've been driving around
show compelling evidence
of the action of water.
But when you look at the minerals
that we've been driving around on,
they are largely sulfate salts
and when you work through the chemistry,
what that tells you is that the water
that was involved in forming
those rocks was very acidic.
It had a PH of three or two or one.
So people run around saying
water on Mars, water on Mars,
well what we really found
evidence for so far,
with Opportunity, is evidence
of sulfuric acid on Mars.
And that's kinda nasty stuff
if you're a microbe, okay.
Of most sorts, however,
clay minerals like these,
those form under neutral PH,
under more normal watery conditions
and so what this evidence points to
is rocks in the rim of this crater
that are fundamentally different
from anything we've seen
before with this rover
after over seven years
of driving it around
and that point to conditions
more suitable for life, possibly
than anything we have found so far.
So here's the road ahead.
Today, this is our position
on day 2585 of the mission,
this is the path going
forwards, four kilometers to go.
Three kilometers to go,
two kilometers to go,
one kilometer to go, and
then here's where we make
our first landfall, if you will.
The places that we're approaching, this
large piece of the rim
here, we named it Cape York.
This gap between it and
the stuff to the south,
we called Botany Bay.
All of these are places that they're named
after places that were
discovered by James Cook
on his expedition of circumnavigation
in the ship Endeavor,
which is what the crater is named after.
So this is the path forward.
We're doing
typically 100-150 meters per drive.
And we drive typically
three or four days a week.
I'll leave it to you to do the math,
but if the wheels don't fall
off, we're gonna get there.
It won't be too long.
The view when we get there
should be spectacular.
This is a perspective view
that shows the topography,
the color code shows
how steep the slopes are
and anything that's red
would be very challenging
for the rover, anything that's black
would be deadly for the rover.
Here's Cape York, here's Botany Bay.
We're out here someplace,
we pull up to this spot
and the view across this
crater's gonna be spectacular.
I can't wait to see it.
One of the things that we're debating
is do we spend a lot of time on Cape York,
which is a little thing,
or do we head south
for the bigger things.
This is a place called Cape Tribulation.
And man, the view from the top of that
would be fantastic, so we'll see.
This is the view looking
off in the distance,
that's Cape Tribulation right here,
Cape York is over that direction,
so like Islands rising
out of a sea of sand,
these things are beckoning to us.
And in the months ahead,
if the rover survives, we'll get there.
Okay, here's another prediction
I'm fairly confident about,
the Cassini Mission.
Cassini's a fantastic mission.
It is an orbiter, currently
orbiting the planet Saturn.
This is a beautiful picture of Saturn,
with the sun shining
through the planet's rings.
Recently, NASA has approved what they call
the Cassini Solstice Mission,
this is a seven year long,
seven years, seven year long extension.
In a sense, it essentially
doubles the mission lifetime
of the Cassini mission.
Among the events that will
take place during the extension
is 54 more flybys of Titan.
Titan is this enormous moon of Saturn,
I'll be talking about it much
more later on in the talk,
it's got a dense
atmosphere, it's got clouds.
The only way you can
really map the surface well
is with radar, so there'll
be 54 more opportunities
to use Radar to gaze through the clouds
and map more of the surface.
Another place that I'll be talking about
later in the talk is Enceladus.
Enceladus is tiny
little moon of Saturn,
it's only 500 kilometers
in diameter, it's bizzarre to think
that a moon that small would
show geological activity,
yet there are literally geysers erupting
from the south pole of Enceladus.
And the Cassini spacecraft
will fly by Enceladus 11 times
and on some of those, it will actually fly
through the plumes of stuff
coming out of those geysers
and make more measurements
of what it is made of.
So the Cassini is going to
continue and is going to continue
to do great science.
Messenger, this is a really exciting one.
Messenger is a mission that
just literally weeks ago
was inserted into orbit around Mercury.
Until Messenger's arrival at Mercury,
the only spacecraft mission
to Mercury had been flybys
by the Mariner 10 spacecraft
back in the mid 70s.
Mercury's a tough place to get to,
it's tough to get to
because you have to go deep
into the sun's gravity well,
it's tough to get to
because it's just hot there.
You'll notice that the spacecraft
is basically equipped with
a giant parasol, okay.
This is a sun shade to keep it cool.
Anyway, it has gone into
orbit around Mercury,
it has just begun to
turn on its instruments
and start to map the planet.
Let me just show you one very cool picture
that came down fairly
recently from Messenger.
They're calling this a spider crater.
Silly names like that are the
ones that scientists make up
to describe things when they don't
actually understand them yet.
But here's an impact
crater, and it's got this
fantastic pattern of grooves
radiating out from it.
Now what's going on here?
Did the crater make the fractures?
Or did the crater form
and weaken the crust
and then later the fractures developed?
Or were the fractures already there
and the crater just luckily
happened to land on top of it?
Don't know.
But this is just an example of the kind of
really spectacular
image data that's coming
out of Messenger, it
also has spectrometers,
will map the surface, tell us what the
planet's crust is made of.
And we're looking forward
to a long and successful
orbiter mission around Mercury.
Okay, so those are venues
that are currently in flight.
Let me talk about one
that hasn't launched yet,
but is getting close to it.
This is an extremely ambitious mission,
called MSL, the Mars Science Laboratory.
And this is another
rover that will follow up
to the discoveries made
with Spirit and Opportunity.
It has a fantastic new scientific payload,
I'll tell you about that in a minute.
And the way this thing lands
is both fascinating and terrifying.
It's shown up here at the upper left
and this is what's called a sky crane.
If you were at my talk yesterday,
I described how Spirit
and Opportunity landed
and it was this terribly
complicated scenario
where we had airbags that
would bounce on the surface
and then deflate and then
the lander would open up
and turn itself right side up
and there were all
these mechanical things,
unfoldings that had to happen
in order to make it work.
And what I always wished was we could just
take the rover and put it
on the surface, you know.
And not have to go through
all that rigamarole.
That's what this thing does,
but it's a little scary.
It comes in with a heat shield,
just like Spirit and Opportunity,
it deploys a parachute,
just like Spirit and Opportunity.
And then what pops out of
the aeroshell is this thing.
And it's a two-part spacecraft.
The top part that you see there
is called the decent stage,
and then here's the rover.
And it flies like this, there's a cable.
It's called a sky crane,
because it is a crane
and there are rocket motors
that are firing up here
and it's lowering this
thing on a rope. (chuckles)
And it flies down together
and if there's winds in
the Martian atmosphere,
it compensates for all those
and the wheels touch down.
It senses touchdown, fires
some explosive devices,
they cut the cables free.
The decent stage flies away
and the rover's sitting there
in the soil, six wheels
in the dirt, ready to go.
If it all works.
We're all very excited and
very nervous about this.
The rover is big.
It's about the size of a Mini Cooper.
One of the things that you'll
notice in this depiction of it
is that there are no solar arrays.
With Spirit and Opportunity,
we are dependent
on solar power for our electrical power
and we are dependent on lucky wind gusts
to clean the solar arrays off
if we wanna keep getting power.
This thing has a big lump of plutonium 238
on the back end of it.
And that's what's called
a radioisotope thermoelectric generator
and that provides a steady
source of electrical power.
Our rovers were designed
to last for 90 days
and we're lucky that they've
lasted six or seven years.
This thing is designed from
the outset to last for years.
It's big, as I said.
The wheels are like this,
it's a very large vehicle.
It carries a very complicated,
very sophisticated science payload.
I won't take you through
the whole payload,
I'll just talk about
this one instrument here.
It's called SAM.
Here it is, just that instrument,
is almost as complicated
as Spirit and Opportunity.
It's a phenomenally complex instrument
and what it does is it is able to detect
organic molecules at the
parts per billion levels
in Martian samples.
So we can reach out with this device here.
Drill into rocks, take
that powdered rock sample,
put it into this device and
search in ancient Martian rocks
for the building blocks of life.
This is going to be a
very exciting mission.
We don't know where we're
gonna land this thing yet.
There are four candidate landing sites,
all of them are very exciting.
Here are two of them.
One thing that characterizes
all of those landing sites
is that they all have clay mounds,
they were chosen for that reason.
This business of finding
clays is terribly important.
Now Spirit and Opportunity
were built by good friends
and colleagues of mine,
people who I respect and love
and I've worked with for years.
Those same people are now
building the MSL rover.
And what I am determined to do
is to get to the clay minerals at Endeavor
before they get to the
clay minerals at this site
with that rover.
I don't know if we'll make it
or not, but we're gonna try.
Anyway, the landing sites are fantastic,
some of them have fixed
sequences of layered sediments.
This is one that clearly
has a delta deposit
where water has flowed into a crater
and deposited these deltaic sediments.
This is gonna be a fantastic mission.
And it's one that we're
all very excited about.
New Horizons has launched
and it's on its way to Pluto.
New Horizons is in the
interesting scenario
where its target was a
planet when it launched
and by the time it gets there,
it's not a planet anymore.
I'm sure many of you
are familiar with this
debate over whether Pluto should
be called a planet or not.
I mean, the real answer is that Pluto
is one of a family of many objects
and if Pluto could be considered a planet,
then all of those other objects
should be considered planets as well.
So from a logical, scientific perspective,
it sort of makes sense to
not consider Pluto a planet.
Personally, I'm a bit of a traditionalist,
when I grew up there were nine planets
and I don't see why Pluto couldn't have
just been grandfathered
in on a technicality, but
anyway that's where it stands.
And it's gonna fly by Pluto and
it's gonna be very exciting.
Okay, so those are some of the missions
that are in the works.
Now let's talk about what comes next.
In convention that one of the things
that I've spent the last
couple years working on,
is this thing we call a Decadal survey.
This is requested by NASA.
It's carried out by the
National Research Council.
It involves inputs form
hundreds and hundreds
of planetary scientists across
the country and overseas.
People here at Berkeley were
very much involved in it
as were many other places.
And it lays out a plan of
exploration for the coming decade.
In our case, it was for
the decade from 2013-2022
so now what I'm gonna do, is
I'm gonna take you through
some of the missions that were recommended
by the Decadal Survey,
both for the next decade and
for the decade beyond that
so the crystal ball's getting
a little cloudier here,
but we're still kinda doing okay.
Now in the process of
generating the recommendations,
of recommending missions
for the Decadal Survey,
we studied a large number
of planetary missions.
28 different missions,
we studied in detail.
And this part of the job
was one of my favorite parts
of the whole thing.
One of the things that I
love about planetary missions
is the part of the process I
call the blank sheet of paper.
When you've got literally
a blank sheet of paper
in front of you, an idea
for something you wanna fly
and you get together a
bunch of smart people
and you start to design a mission.
And it's a fascinating, exhilarating
very complicated part of the job.
And we sort of got to do the
blank sheet of paper thing
about 28 times over in the
course of doing this study
and then of course, once
we'd studied those missions,
we had to pick the few
best ones to recommend.
But here's just a list
of all the missions.
And I'm not gonna read
all of these to you,
but I'll go through a few of them.
Mercury Lander, just what it sounds like,
follows on after and lands on Mercury.
This Venus in Situ Explorer,
that's a Venus Lander.
Venus Mobile Explorer, that's
lander that lands on Venus,
takes off, and then goes and lands again.
Lunar South Pole Aitken
Basin Sample Return,
there's a huge impact basin
on the far side of the moon.
Remember all the Apollo landings
were on the lunar near side
because the astronauts
needed to talk to Earth.
But on the other side of the moon,
there's a huge impact basin
that punched completely through
the lunar crust and down
into the lunar mantle.
And so if you can go to
the other side of the moon,
land by that impact basin and get ejected
from that basin, you could get
pieces of the lunar mantle.
It's a way to actually get inside the moon
and then you bring those back.
Bunch of Mars missions.
I'll talk about several of these,
the Mars sample return is certainly
the most complex and
ambitious of all of them.
Outer solar system, Europa.
Europa is this moon of Jupiter
that has a crust of ice
and probably an ocean of
liquid water under that ice.
That makes it a tremendously
important target.
I'll talk about that mission
in a lot more detail.
Io, Io is another moon of Jupiter,
it is the most geologically,
most volcanically active body
in the solar system.
Saturn Probe, this puts an entry probe
into the atmosphere of Saturn.
When Cassini went to
Saturn, there was an orbiter
and there was an atmospheric probe
but that atmospheric
probe went into Titan.
It went into the atmosphere
of Titan, one of the moons.
We have never put anything
into Saturn's atmosphere.
And this one would fill
the gap in that knowledge.
Titan Lake Lander.
It's a boat, there are lakes
of liquid methane and ethane
on Titan and this would actually
go sailing in one of those lakes.
These are some cool ones, Uranus Orbiter,
Neptune Orbiter and Probe Missions.
There are basically three kinds of planets
in the solar system, there
are the terrestrial planets,
the rocky worlds, Mercury,
Venus, Earth, Mars.
We've done a lot with those.
There are the gas giants,
the two big gaseous planets
made mostly of hydrogen and helium,
that's Jupiter and Saturn, we've done
the Galileo misison of Jupiter,
the Cassini mission of Saturn.
And then there are the ice
giants, Uranus and Neptune
and they're made of very different stuff
from any of those other planets.
And in contrast to those other planets,
all we've ever done
with Uranus and Neptune
is 2 flybys back with
the Voyager 2 mission,
using early 70s technology.
So there's enormous potential
for new discoveries here.
And then you get to the smaller bodies,
return a sample from an asteroid,
land on an asteroid,
very interesting object called Chiron,
this is an object that's
out between the orbit
of Saturn and Uranus, nothing else like it
in the solar system.
Comet surface sample return,
return a sample from the
surface of a comet nucleus.
So 28 missions, great fun studying them,
the hard part was picking the best
from this to recommend for flight.
So let me talk to you now about some
of the recommended missions.
This is one, it's called
a Mars Trace Gas Orbiter.
Recently there's been a
very interesting discovery
that's been made regarding
the Martian atmosphere.
Shown in this picture
here, these are mostly
earth based observations
and what they have shown
is evidence for methane
in the atmosphere of Mars.
Now what's unusual about that
is that if you ask yourself
how long will a methane molecule last
in the Martian atmosphere?
The answer is measured in
years, or 10s of years,
or maybe like 100 years,
it's very very short.
Those molecules don't last long
because they're easily destroyed
by ultraviolet radiation and
lots of ultraviolet radiation
hits the top of the Martian atmosphere.
So if we're seeing, we're
really seeing methane
in the atmosphere and what
that says is that there
is some active source of methane
at or below the Martian surface.
What makes methane,
cows make methane, it's probably not cows.
Various forms of microbial
life make methane,
in fact it's microbes inside the cows
that make that methane.
And then volcanoes can
make methane as well.
But what this says, this
observation is saying
that if this is correct, Mars is either
volcanically or
biologically active or both.
And so this is a mission with a spacecraft
that would be built by
the European Space Agency
with NASA, providing most
of the science payload
and the launch and would
follow upon these observations
and try to identify the
specific sources of methane
and its detailed concentrations
in the atmosphere.
Beyond that, one of NASA's
programs of planetary exploration
is a program of missions, it's called
the New Frontiers program.
That mission to Pluto that I described
is the first of the
New Frontiers missions.
And the way New Frontiers works is
we recommend a small list, a short list
of potential missions and
then groups of scientists
get together, team up, write proposals
for missions that can cost
up to like a billion dollars,
and one of those missions gets selected
from those proposals,
so it's a competitive selection
among a limited number
of candidate missions.
New Horizons, the Pluto
mission is the first,
there's a mission called Juno
that's gonna go to Jupiter
that's the second New Frontiers mission.
There's a third one that's in the process
of being selected right now and we said,
okay, NASA should pick two
more New Frontier missions
the fourth and the fifth
one in this coming decade.
We recommended that the fourth one,
so the next one selected
in the coming decade
should be chosen from among these five.
Of all those mission
candidates that I talked about,
these were some of the
ones that bubbled up
to the top, just based
on their science return.
Comet Surface Sample Return.
I'll show you this one in a
little more detail in a moment,
returning samples from
the surface of the comet.
There's lunar sample return
mission from the lunar far side,
getting inside the moon.
The Saturn Probe Mission.
Trojan Tour and Rendezvous.
There are these objects
called Trojan asteroids
that are the same orbit
around the sun as Jupiter,
they share Jupiter's orbit.
And they're 60 degrees ahead
of or 60 degrees behind
Jupiter at that planet's Lagrange
points, as they're known.
And this was a mission that
would go ahead and explore those
and then here's that Venus lander misison.
So what w recommend,
these are the top five,
and we recommended that if
none of these things have flown
by the time NASA makes its selection,
that the fourth New Frontiers mission,
selected sometime around 2015 or so,
should be chosen from
these five and we leave it
up to the competition that
will be held to decide
which one will actually go,
and the best mission wins.
Then another, oh, five or so years later,
NASA should pick another one
and which one should
they pick, it should be
whatever's left over from those five,
and then we're gonna throw
two more into the mix.
One is the Io mission, this is a mission
that would orbit Jupiter
and do many flybys
of this violently active volcanic moon.
And then a lunar geophysical network.
Now you might say, well wait a minute,
we put a bunch of geophysical stations,
seismometers on the moon back on Apollo.
Didn't we?
Yeah, but again, all the Apollo landings
were on the near side of
the moon, which means that
all of those seismomenters are
on the same side of the moon.
That's not a good way to find out
about the deep interior of the moon,
you want to have them
distributed over the lunar globe.
And so this is a mission
that would do that.
So those are the recommended
moderate cost missions.
Now we get to the good stuff.
The expensive ones, oh.
Forgot about this one, yeah comets.
I promised you I was gonna tell you
about one of these missions.
This is what comet nuclei look like.
Comet nuclei are tiny little things,
a few kilometers in
size, these are a couple
that we have flown by.
The thing that's great about comets
is not just that they're photogenic,
it's what they're made of.
And here's a list of some
of the constituent molecules
of comets, the things
that stream off of a comet
when they get close to the sun.
And you see things like water,
okay that's interesting.
We need water for life, we need water,
water is what makes up our oceans,
much of the water on earth
may have come from comets,
but you also find things like methane,
there's ethane up there, there's
complex hydrocarbons, ammonia, cyanide,
there's all sorts of
interesting things in comets.
The building blocks of life on Earth
were probably in large measures
delivered to Earth initially from comets.
There are molecules in your body
that got to Earth by being
delivered from comets
and so this is a way to study
our planet's building blocks
and the building blocks of life.
It's a complicated mission.
This is what the spacecraft looks like.
Comets go pretty far from the sun.
And you wanna actually encounter a comet
when it's far from the sun
because when its far from the sun
is when it's cold and
that's when you don't have
a lot of stuff streaming off of it.
But when you go far from the sun,
you need great big solar
arrays for electrical power.
This thing would hover
above a comet nucleus,
go down to the surface and then
use kind of a spinning brush
to brush material off of the surface
and suck it into a container.
The container would then be launched
on a trajectory that would ultimately
bring it back to Earth,
it's a complicated mission.
Okay, now we get to the flagships,
the really expensive missions.
The highest priority flagship mission
that we recommended for the coming decade
is to begin the process of
returning samples from Mars.
We have gotten to the point
now where our understanding
of Mars is so good, that we can identify
the right places to go
on the Martian surface
to bring back the most interesting rocks
and despite the fact that we can build
fantastic instruments,
and take them to the
Martian surface with rovers
like MSL, the best instrumentation
is always gonna be the
stuff that's back on Earth.
Because when you get
these rocks back to Earth
and you can use very
sophisticated analysis techniques,
you can find out things about these rocks
that you could never ever hope to do
on the planet's surface.
So Mars sample return has sort of been
the holy grail of Mars
science for a very long time.
And what this program does
is it breaks the process
of sample return down into three parts.
Three successive missions,
here's how the scenario goes.
The first mission, which we
recommend to fly in 2018,
goes to the Martian
surface before the rover,
a little bigger than
Spirit and Opportunity.
That rover drives around
an interesting site,
selects samples, collects
them, and places them into
a container, a sample cache.
Which is then on the Martian surface.
And that's all it does.
They're gonna come back eventually,
but what that first mission
does is simply collect
the right samples.
The second mission then
sends another vehicle
that lands close to that sample cache.
A little rover goes over,
gets the cache, brings it back
and sticks it into the
nosecone of a little rocket,
cranks it up to a vertical position,
shoots that sample cache
contained in a spacecraft
the size of a coconut
into orbit around Mars.
So now that coconut sized
spacecraft is orbiting Mars.
Now a third mission, stay with me on this.
A third mission comes and
in the vastness of space
around that Mars, finds
that coconut, gathers it in,
places it into a return
capsule and sends it
on a trajectory back
to Earth where it lands
in the desert of Utah with a thump
about 25 years from now.
And the samples come back to Earth.
It's a hard thing to do, folks.
The way you would land
would be, again, using this
terrifying sky crane system,
this is the descent stage
that's been developed for
the Mars science laboratory.
Now this mission, when it
was originally proposed to us
on the Decadal Survey,
was a joint enterprise
between NASA and ESA, they
would actually land two rovers
at the same site, one NASA
rover, one ESA, European rover.
This is what the NASA
rover would look like,
it's name right now is MAX-C,
which stands for Mars
Astrobiology Explorer
with Cacheing, I think.
And it drives around, it's got this
fiendishly complicated
thing on the front end of it
that collects the samples
and puts them in the cache
and that's the job of this rover.
The European rover and
the original concept
was called ExoMars.
And the highlight of
ExoMars was that it carries
a drill that is able to
drill one to two meters
down below the Martian surface
and get samples from there.
Very exciting pair of missions.
What we found, when we
studied them together,
however was that flying two
rovers was simply too expensive.
The cost to NASA of
flying these two rovers
was gonna be $3.5 billion,
which was just too much.
So what we recommended was that
NASA needs to work together
to simplify that mission and right now
the two agencies are
collaborating trying to find a way
to take those two rovers and
combine them into just one.
And reduce the cost of
the mission substantially.
But the idea is that first
mission creates a sample cache.
Then here's the second mission,
it too carries a little rover.
This is called a fetch rover
because it's job is to go fetch
the catche, brings it back.
Puts it into the nose
cone of this rocket here
called the Mars Ascent Vehicle.
And that blasts that
precious coconut into orbit.
And here's the coconut collector mission.
There's the sample cache
right there, orbiting Mars.
And this orbiter goes and
fetches it, catches it,
puts it into this sample return canister
and sends it back to Earth.
When it gets back to Earth, it goes
into a sample receiving facility.
This is what the sample
return canister looks like,
the thing that's gonna come back to Earth
and if you look at that for a minute,
you see the heat shield, you
see the sample return canister,
you see some cushioning
material around it.
Notice what's missing?
There's no parachute.
There's no parachute, why
isn't there a parachute?
Well the answer to that is that
people, rightly so I think,
are concerned that you
don't want to inadvertently
release Martian materials into
the terrestrial environment.
Now not too many of us
believe that there are
dangerous organisms that are
gonna be brought back from Mars
and be inside this capsule,
but you shouldn't be reckless
about such things and so you are required,
quite sensibly to build a capsule
that is so rugged that even
if no parachute deploys,
when it hits the ground,
it will not break,
it will not fracture the samples,
it will not release the samples
so if you've got a sample
container that's tough enough
to not need a parachute,
don't fly a parachute.
So it actually doesn't have
one, it lands pretty hard.
But that's the idea.
Alright.
This one's a real
favorite of mine, Europa.
Europa is, as I said
it's a moon of Jupiter.
It's roughly the size of the Earth's moon.
We know from its density
that it must be made
mostly of rock and metal.
And yet its surface is made of ice.
It's made primarily of
water ice and it is laced
with this intricate,
complex pattern of fractures
that suggests that that
icy shell has been deformed
and fractured and cracked
in various complex ways.
If you ask yourself what does
Europa look like on the inside
there are both theoretical calculations
and observations from
the Galileo spacecraft
that suggest very strongly
that it looks something like this.
You have a small metallic core,
you have a big mantle if
you will of rocky material,
and then when you get
close to the surface,
here's that rocky material,
there's the crust of ice
but both the calculations
and the observations suggest
that this icy crust is pretty thin
and beneath it lies an ocean,
an ocean of liquid water.
And what that means if it's true,
is that there are two
kind of accessible oceans
in the solar system, we've got one
and Europa's got the other.
That's a tremendously exciting thing,
because again, water is
a necessity for life.
Now another necessity for
life is some form of energy.
So you might ask yourself well, okay sure,
there's an ocean there, but
if you wanna have organisms
live in that ocean, what
are they gonna live off of?
What's their energy source?
Ice is opaque enough that
you can't expect sunlight
to shine down through that
stuff and have photosynthetic
organisms living in that ocean, okay.
That's not gonna work, 'cause this ice
might be 10 kilometers thick
or something like that.
But see this red stuff here?
What that's representing
is the idea that inside
this rocky mantle,
temperatures are high enough
that you can get undersea volcanism,
that you can get volcanic
activity taking place
on Europa's seafloor.
And we know that on Earth's seafloor,
volcanic activity and
the hydrothermal vents
that are associated with
that support complex
biological activity that
is fundamentally energized.
That derives it metabolic
energy from the planet's
internal geophysical heat.
So Europa and this environment right here
is one of the most compelling
places in the solar system
to look for evidence of life.
And that's a hard thing to do.
And we're not gonna send
a submarine the first time
we go to Europa.
We don't know how to do that.
The big question is how thick is the ice?
Where are the thin spots?
But see the idea is that
you would fly a mission
that would contain a number,
it would carry a number of instruments.
One of the most exciting
is a long wavelength radar.
And the way we have mapped the thickness
of the Greenland ice sheet,
of the Antarctic ice sheet,
and mapped the rock
underneath is by using radar
at long wavelengths that can
see through kilometers of ice.
Well the same thing will work on Europa.
And you can use that system
to look through that ice,
find the thin spots, find the place to go
with a lander mission or
with a submarine mission.
So this is a very very exciting mission.
The cost estimates for this
one came out very high.
It came out at $4.7 billion,
which was the number
that broke my heart.
And we're looking right now, very hard
at ways to make that less expensive
but still get the job done.
Uranus and Neptune, another
one of our recommended missions
is the Uranus orbiter and probe.
This is like a Cassini
mission, or Galileo mission
to Uranus and it would go to Uranus,
it would put an orbiter into
orbit around the planet,
multiple flybys of Uranus,
moons, good observations
of the rings, and then a probe that would
go into the planet's atmosphere.
Now why, you might ask,
Uranus instead of Neptune?
You know either one would be great.
They're both gonna be fantastic.
The reason that we recommended Uranus
for the coming decade is
that when you simply look
at the spacecraft trajectories
that are necessary
to get from Earth to these planets,
the spacecraft trajectories
that go to Uranus
in the next decade are just more favorable
than the ones that go to Neptune.
Also Neptune requires
some special technologies
including one called
aerocapture, where basically
you drag the spacecraft
through the planet's atmosphere
to slow it down.
But Uranus does not.
Which makes Uranus easier to do.
But either one of those,
Uranus or Neptune,
could be a fantastic mission
for the decade to come
or the one after that.
Here's another good one, Enceladus.
This is that crazy little
icy moon of Saturn.
500 kilometers in diameter,
tiny little thing.
But there are these prominent fractures
near the south pole of Titan.
And erupting from those fractures
are these plumes of material.
And there's fantastic
stuff in those plumes.
The Cassini spacecraft has
flown through those plumes
and has measured the composition
and there's lots of water.
But there's also methane,
there's ammonia, there's CO2,
there's complex organics.
There's interesting stuff going
on down inside of Enceladus.
Now Cassini flies through it occasionally,
but the idea here would
be to send an orbiter
to Enceladus that could really
study that moon in detail,
that could do many many
flybys through the plume
that would have a very
sophisticated payload
that is specifically aimed at
really studying those plumes
and learning what they
tell us about conditions
down inside of Enceladus.
Titan, fantastic place.
Titan is roughly the size
of the planet Mercury.
It's a moon of Saturn
that's made mostly of ice,
has a dense atmosphere,
the atmosphere is made
mostly of nitrogen, same
thing that is the primary gas
in the Earth's atmosphere.
The atmospheric pressure
at the surface of Titan
is 50% higher than the
atmospheric pressure on Earth,
it's a dense atmosphere.
It's got cloud cover, a
haze of hydrocarbon smog.
There's methane in the atmosphere of Titan
and when you shine ultraviolet
radiation on methane,
what happens again is
the molecules break up.
But on Titan there's so much of it
that they can recombine
into more complex organics
and it makes this smog
that obscures the surface,
but when you use radar
to look through that smog
you find this complicated icy surface
and then what you find is
that Titan actually has
a hydrological cycle, it rains
on Titan, there are rivers.
There are lakes, but
the fluid in the rivers,
but the fluid in rivers,
the fluid in the lakes,
the fluid in the rain is not water,
it's liquid methane and ethane.
And it produces these phenomenal features
with dendritic valleys
and these very familiar looking things
and yet the fluid is methane and ethane.
So we looked at a mission
that would study these
in comprehensive detail.
You can do some kinda
cool things on Titan.
You can put a little boat into the lake.
You can fly a balloon in the atmosphere.
You can fly an orbiter around the planet,
around the moon with radar.
This mission costed out at $6.7 billion,
which was even more
expensive but this is one
that has great potential for the future.
Now that was a mission that
would try to do a comprehensive
study of Titan, understand
the hydrological cycle,
understand the climate,
understand the geophysics.
A different approach is to say look,
this is a very complex interesting object,
but the most interesting
thing is the lakes
so let's just go there.
So this is a mission that we looked at
that was just targeted at Titan's lakes,
and you can see our
radar picture that shows
some of these lakes here.
This picture, you've gotta
sorta stare at this for a minute
to realize what you're looking at.
This is a picture of the spacecraft.
And this image is taken
from, I'll say underwater.
Looking up at the surface,
now it's not water,
it's liquid methane, but here is the boat.
The underside of the
boat, you an see Saturn
hanging in the sky.
But this is looking up at
the underside of the boat
and here's the little
submarine that it just dropped
to go down to the bottom of the lake.
And it consists of two pieces.
One of which is heavy,
dense, negatively buoyant
and the other is positively buoyant.
And this thing has all
sorts of cool stuff on it.
My favorite instrument
here is a rain gauge.
You know, that's not
something you usually put
on a spacecraft, but this would
actually have a rain gauge
on the boat to look at how much rain,
methane rain falls out
of the sky of Titan.
And this sort of shows
the mission profile,
this is a little bit hard
to read but basically
what this thing does is the
boat lands at the surface
and then it releases the submarine.
The submarine is in two parts
and when those two parts
are joined together,
it's negatively buoyant,
in other words it sinks.
And it drops slowly to the bottom
and it sits there for a
while making measurements
at the bottom of a methane lake on Titan.
Makes its measurements for a
while and then once it's done,
it fires a little
explosive squib right here
that cuts the top part
free from the bottom part.
The top part is positively buoyant.
It floats and so now it
drifts back up to the surface,
comes up to the surface
and transmits its data
to a spacecraft orbiting Titan
which then relays it back to Earth.
If you don't think this is cool,
I don't know what to do.
What I just described to
you is probably a good,
easily 25 years, 25 or 30 years
worth of planetary exploration.
It's expensive stuff.
We've worked very hard to come up
with realistic cost
estimates for these missions.
The missions that are expensive
we are working really hard to
bring the costs of those down.
But carrying out these
missions will require
significant funding.
And the funding needs to stay
steady or go up a little bit
going forward to kind of do the program
that I've laid out for you.
Now in recent months, we have received
from the Obama administration, projections
going forward for funding
for planetary exploration
in the United States
for the next five years.
The funding that's recommended
for fiscal year 2012,
here's the number for 2010, $1.3 billion.
For 2012, it's $1.488
billion, that's a good number.
That's a number that's
consistent with the plan
that I laid out for you, that's a number
that will allow us to do
these exciting missions going forward.
But then it falls off a cliff.
The projected numbers from
the Obama administration
go $1.36, $1.32, $1.27,
$1.18 in fiscal year 2016.
And this does not account for inflation,
so it's actually worse than this.
The buying power is going
down even more sharply
than what I've described here.
Now these are
the word that they use in Washington DC
to describe this budget is notional.
I find that an amusing
word, but the idea is
this is a real number, everything else
is a shot across our bow.
It's telling us that this is
what we the administration
intend to carry out.
Now of course, the budget
has to actually be enacted
by the congress and it's signed
into law by the president.
And there's some in
congress who look at this
and see the demise of
planetary exploration
in the United States.
If this budget happens, then
the inexpensive missions
that I mentioned,
like the New Frontiers
missions that I talked about,
those we can still afford.
But the flagship missions,
sample return, Europa,
Uranus, none of that can happen.
The multi-billion dollar,
even the billion dollar,
two billion dollar class
missions, they go away.
The United States can't do them anymore.
Now this is what the Obama administration
has proposed, Congress has to act on this.
The people in congress are
our elected representatives
and if you feel strongly
that we should be continuing
to do a program of robotic
planetary exploration
that keeps this country at
the forefront of that field
with samples coming back from Mars
and orbiters to Europa,
now would not be a bad time to let
your congressional representatives know
that a budget like this
is one that's gonna take
us out of that business.
I however remain optimistic.
I believe that ultimately, we are gonna
do missions of the sort
that I just described,
and that when you look in the decades
down beyond that, here's
where I'm waving my arms
and speculating that
even better things await.
So let me just describe for you
a few kind of really longer term things
that I'd love to see happen.
One of them is returning
samples from Enceladus.
I mentioned that mission that
would fly through the plumes,
here's one where you produce a collector,
this is a material that you
can put out in the breeze
and you can fly through
one of these plumes,
the plume particles impact
it, they get decelerated
by this collector and then you send
the whole thing back to Earth.
You don't actually have
to land on Enceladus,
you just collect the material.
That would be a fantastic mission.
Another one, obviously, is humans to Mars.
Now sending humans to Mars has
been 30 years in the future
for the last 30 years, so it's
gonna be at least 30 years
before this happens, but despite the fact
that you can do marvelous
things with robotic explorers
on the Martian surface,
the best exploration
and I believe the most
inspiring exploration as well
is ultimately gonna be done by humans.
And I think sending humans to Mars
is something that should
and will lie in our future.
And I think personally that Mars
is a much better target
for human exploration
than the moon or asteroids,
because frankly, the moon or asteroids
you can do pretty well with robots.
Mars is so complicated that humans
can really contribute there.
I'm not sure if they
would wanna drive around
in something that looks like this,
but they can do a good job.
Finally, this is one of my real favorites.
You know I've often said
that if I could figure out
how to do submarines on Europa,
I wouldn't be messing
around with rovers on Mars.
This is a fiendishly complex mission.
You need to go deep into
Jupiter's gravity well
and land on the surface of Europa.
Europa lies deep in
Jupiter's magnetic field
and so your spacecraft
is subjected to punishing
charged particle radiation.
Somehow then, you have to drill or melt
your way down through, oh I don't know,
10 kilometers of ice
and then release into this water column,
which might be 100 kilometers deep,
a free swimming autonomous vehicle
that's able to somehow
navigate its way down
to the bottom of the ocean,
find whatever interesting
stuff lies there,
collect data about it and then somehow
get that information back, transmitting it
to this thing, which
transmits it to the surface,
which transmits it to an orbiter,
which transmits it to Earth.
I wanna see this mission happen.
I'm trying to get lots of exercise,
eat healthy foods, I'm gonna
have to live a long time
to see this mission happen.
But I truly hope that it will.
The big question of course, then is what
will all of these missions discover,
my answer is, I don't know,
you've gotta ask this guy.
Thank you very much.
(applause)
- [Man] First thing I wanted to ask about
is the sample return mission.
- From Mars?
- [Man] Yeah.
Why is it still being considered
to do the analysis on Earth
rather than at the space station,
given the possibility of contamination?
- Bunch of reasons for that.
I think probably the most important one
is that we really do know how to deal with
the contamination problem.
The contamination problem is very similar
to ones that phase
people were working with,
various disease agents
an that sort of thing.
There are facilities that
can contain such things
so it's a tractable problem.
You can put much, much,
much better instrumentation
into laboratories on
Earth than you can put
in the space station.
And it just sort of puts off the problem.
I mean if you contaminate
the space station,
then what do you do?
So doing it on Earth is the
sensible place, I think.
- [Man] And I've read that there is,
it's thought that there
may be a liquid ocean
underneath ice crusts on
Ganymede and Enceladus
as well.
- Enceladus and Ganymede
both possibly, I think
Enceladus it's more likely
just sort of little liquid zones.
Ganymede, quite possibly but the reason
that Europa is more
attractive than Ganymede,
is that on Ganymede that ice crust
is really, really, really thick.
It's much more accessible on Europa.
- [Man] Thant's what I thought, thank you.
- Sure.
Hi.
- [Man] One of the problems
of prolonging space travel
for humans is that it's
detrimental to their bodies.
- Yes it is.
- And I wish you could talk
a little bit about that.
- Sure.
Spaceflight is tough on
human bodies in several ways.
One is that long term
exposure to microgravity
results in redistribution
of a variety of fluids
and electrolytes in your body
and one of the consequences of
that is bone decalcification.
A lot of the work that's
going on in the space station
right now is to develop
countermeasures for that
and those are moderately
effective, so I think
it takes seven months to get to Mars,
we can probably solve that problem.
Another serious problem is radiation.
And solar flares can produce
intense radiation bursts
that could be very
detrimental to human health.
Both on their way to Mars
and on the Martian surface.
The way to deal with that is shielding.
You just need a lot of mass
between you and the sun.
The thing about these solar flares is
you can sorta see them
coming, the particle flecks
just don't travel at the speed of light,
you find out that this thing is coming
and as long as the astronauts
have someplace to go hide,
they're gonna be okay.
The way you hide on a
spacecraft on the way to Mars
is if you carry with you
some significant mass
that you use for shielding
that you would take mass that's
good for something else too,
like water or something and then you have
a little small place where you can go
to keep yourself safe
until the flare is over.
On the Martian surface
it gets a little easier,
becasue basically what you do
is you build a storm cellar
okay, you dig a hole
beneath the Martian surface
and as long as you're a meter or two down,
you're gonna be okay when
a solar flare happens.
But it is a serious problem and one
that could be very detrimental
to astronaut health
unless the appropriate
shielding is available.
- Hi you mentioned a lot of exploration
on Mars, specifically towards craters.
Why are you looking only at craters,
like why is that a big deal?
- Oh yeah, the reason
that we focus so much
on the impact craters with
the rover Opportunity.
The reason for that is simple.
The rocks that we've
been driving around on
for the last seven years
are sedimentary rocks
and they're a bunch of horizontal layers.
And they're very flat lying
and the surface itself
is very flat too, so as you're
driving along that surface,
you're basically just
seeing the same rocks
over and over and over again.
What you want to do is have the capability
to get down below the surface.
Now we don't have a drill, okay.
We didn't bring a backhoe, we have no way
of digging a hole, but what we can do
is rely on the holes that
nature has dug for us
in the form of impact craters.
So the beauty of these impact craters
is that they provide
access to other layers
in that stack of sediments,
each of which represent a different page
in the Martian history book.
And so we're able to
study those other rocks
by going to craters.
That's the reason we do it.
- Great, thank you.
- Sure.
Hi.
- I have a question about there's
some limited private funds
going into space exploration, do you think
that that will effect the
economy of space exploration
in the longer term or is
it just a Martian thing?
- The private funding that's
being invested in space
right now is almost all
money that is intended
to return a profit to the investors.
There are a couple of examples,
one is Virgin Galactic.
And they have built a
spacecraft that will be able
to take passengers, I mean
it's not orbiting the Earth,
it's just a ballistic trajectory
where you have maybe 15
minutes of zero gravity
going over the top, but
you get to the fringes
of space and back again
and people can pay,
I forget what the going price is,
it's the border of
$10,000 to go on that ride
and the company makes money.
Another great example is SpaceX.
This is a company I have a lot
of enthusiasm and respect for
and this is a company that's
a privately owned company
started by Elon Musk, the
same guy who started PayPal.
And they are developing rockets called
the Falcon family of rockets,
Falcon 9 and Falcon Heavy
that they hope and I hope will
be able to deliver payloads
to Earth orbit for paying customers
at a much lower cost than
we typically now spend
for our Delta rockets
and our Atlas rockets
from some of the more
traditional aerospace companies.
So we are now beginning
to see private enterprise
really start to be major
players in the space business,
but all of the examples that I know of
rely on a sound business model
that has paying customers
lined up and ready to pay
real money for those services.
Finding people who were
willing to pay lots of money
for data from Uranus,
rocks from Mars, that's a little tougher.
So there are some things that I think
for the foreseeable future,
we have to rely on the
government to take care of.
- Thank you all for coming.
- Thank you.
- And Steve, thanks for
an exciting talk again.
(upbeat music)